with something as serious as the
wielding state power to kill somebody
there should be maximum transparency and
what was happening at the moment which
is maximum censorship though the death
penalty remains legal in the majority of
American states only a handful of them
actually carry out executions numbering
in the few dozens annually part of the
reason the American public maintains a
steadfast support of its government
killing convicted murderers is due to
the fact that our executions are cloaked
in secrecy and largely sold to the
public as a medical procedure akin to
putting a sick animal to sleep but a
series of botched executions in 2014
have exposed a problem largely unknown
to the American public the drugs
currently used for lethal injections are
experimental untested and proving to be
ineffective at killing prisoners without
excruciating pain reason TV asked Edie
Pilkington chief reporter for The
Guardian us and Richard dieter the
executive director of the death penalty
Information Center about the disparity
between Americans support for the death
penalty and the dearth of information
available to the public regarding
executions since the 70s America has
tried to sanitize the way it kills
people in death chambers you know it's
not driven by sympathy for the
defendants who did terrible crimes we
don't want to hear gruesome facts about
execution we don't want to hear people
squirming on the gurney and their
children watching as they're being
executed and by using pharmaceutical
drugs to to do the killing they're
implying that this process is painless
it's humane it's very civilized and
they've used that as a way of
undermining resistance and opposition to
the death penalty but now we're seeing
pharmaceutical companies government's
the European Union protest groups all
saying hang on this is wrong medical
drugs
created in order to save lives in order
to make people's health better they are
not created to kill people faced with a
European Union ban on selling drugs used
in lethal injections death penalty
states now rely on compounding
pharmacies usually small businesses who
will produce execution cocktails made to
order these drugs are unregulated by the
FDA and their manufacturers are cloaked
in secrecy Oklahoma is one of these
states and when Clayton Lockett was
executed in April 2014 a procedure was
anything but quick and painless it took
43 minutes from the time the first
needle was inserted in lockets
for him to die see it was groaning he
was shouting out they were fighting
impossible to get a vein so blood was
spurting all over the people in the
death chamber I mean it wasn't the most
horrendous situation and right at that
moment they decided to shut the curtain
which would prevent any witnesses
including reporters from seeing what
happened so there you have I think in
most visceral form the censorship that's
going on first off you have censorship
of surrounding the drugs and where they
came from so that you can't do a Public
Interest job as a journalist to check
whether those drugs were sufficient
standard to do a proper job then when
everything goes wrong you shut the
curtain so we can't see what happens and
that's the kind of debts that these
death penalty states are now succumbing
to with something as serious as the
wielding of state power to kill somebody
there should be maximum transparency and
not what's happening at the moment which
is maximum censorship Missouri is one of
13 states which have expanded what are
called black hood laws meant to protect
the identity of executioner's to now
also make confidential the identities of
everyone involved in the production and
delivery of lethal injection drugs these
laws even supersede the Freedom of
Information Act in response
The Guardian The Associated Press and
several prominent Missouri newspapers
have filed suit against the state in
what is believed to be the first lawsuit
to challenge the death penalty on First
Amendment grounds there is a provision
in the First Amendment that says the
public and we as journalists as part of
the public should have access to key
elements of government operations it's
why the public is allowed into a
courtroom we think they shouldn't just
apply within the courtroom situation
within a trial it should apply to the
end of the process in a capital case
which is when someone is executed in the
death chamber and everything to do with
that execution process the public should
have First Amendment access to even
anti-death-penalty politicians like
Virginia's Governor Terry McAuliffe are
in support of increased secrecy
regarding lethal injections because the
alternative would be to bring back
grisly reforms of execution like the
firing squad which Utah is considering
or even the gas chamber which Missouri
is contemplating so states have all
scrambled to block media the public even
the courts from knowing where these
execution drugs come from theory is that
these companies won't provide the drugs
if their names are in the paper because
after all they're not in the business of
perfecting executions look if you're
building bridges tell us where you get
the the bolts from and if the bridge
collapse we want to know who's
responsible professionals you don't have
to tell us the name of every Riveter but
we gotta know who caused this and if you
think about it there cannot be anything
as important as the state killing
somebody the more state power that is
wielded we believe the more transparency
there should be and what's actually
happening in death penalty states is the
opposite from that they are giving less
and less information to the public no
date has been set for the Missouri
lawsuit but in the meantime death row
inmates in several states have filed
suit on the grounds that the drugs that
they are to be killed with may violate
their Eighth Amendment rights
prohibiting cruel and unusual punishment
I think it goes back to the sort of
school a public squeamishness about
what's being done going back to these
methods that are very hard to describe
as civilized or painless or humane you
know firing squad or electric chair
which you know is anything but painless
or the gas chamber which of course has
ramifications of what happened in
Germany in the in the 40s which is
pretty chilling but for me that talks to
to the existence of the death penalty
itself I mean if people aren't prepared
to see what is being done in their name
then perhaps they shouldn't be doing it